tenemos cuatro compuestos diferentes y
también sus masas molares ahora quiero
que piensen en cuál de estos compuestos
tiene el mayor porcentaje de azufre por
masa pausa en el vídeo y traten de
resolver esto por su cuenta muy bien una
forma de resolver esto es decir que por
mol de cada compuesto podemos calcular
cuántos gramos tiene yo diría cuál es la
masa del azufre dividida entre la masa
total del compuesto podemos ver que en
el mol de cada uno de estos compuestos
hay un molde azufre en cada una de estas
fórmulas vemos exactamente un azufre por
lo que en todas estas situaciones la
masa del azufre va a ser la misma va a
ser igual en todos los compuestos esto
no se cumpliría si alguno de los
compuestos tuviera dos azufre o alguno
tuviera tres o quizá algunos no tuvieran
alguno pero todos ellos tienen un azufre
por lo que en un molde cada uno de estos
compuestos vamos a tener un molde azufre
así que tendremos la misma masa de
azufre podemos ver la tabla periódica y
ver que la masa atómica del azufre es
32.06 por lo que si tenemos un molde
azufre serán 32 puntos 0 6 gramos
esto es 32.06 gramos para todos los
casos porque nuevamente tenemos un molde
azufre en el molde cada uno de estos
compuestos ya que sólo hay un azufre en
cada una de estas fórmulas la idea aquí
es que para todos estos casos vamos a
tener el mismo valor en el numerador y
queremos encontrar el porcentaje más
grande entonces queremos minimizar el
valor en el denominador por lo que
debemos encontrar cuál de éstos tiene el
menor denominador o cuál tiene la masa
más baja por molde las moléculas otra
forma de pensar en esto es cuál de éstos
tiene la menor masa molar y podemos ver
claramente que este compuesto de aquí
tiene la menor masa molar con esto
terminamos este tiene el mayor
porcentaje de azufre por masa porque por
mol tiene la misma masa de azufre como
todas las demás pero tiene la menor masa
total así que va a tener el mayor
porcentaje de azufre
una forma rápida de hacer esto es
fijarnos en la masa molar más baja
aunque también podríamos haber tomado
32.06 y dividirlo por cada uno de estos
valores y calcular el porcentaje pero no
nos piden calcular el porcentaje nos
preguntan cuál es el que tiene el
porcentaje más alto y ese es el segundo
compuesto de aquí